a lot you know it's funny because i'll
be talking to so many random people and
they'll be like oh i got up i got a
blast hook from like three years ago i
just been waiting to put it out and i'll
be like hey yeah good luck with that you
know i'm not coming out buddy how long
how many does that happen often because
you you've been active in the scene for
a very long time like um obviously
on the production side um
you know i'm sure tons of people have
old [ __ ] from you i did so much in the
past i i forgot certain things do stuff
come out sometimes like hit the dsps
without you guys even clearing it and
you guys gotta take send it right to
carl take him down take that down
carl cherry not carl fox oh okay who's
gonna who's just my attorney okay your
attorney's the one huh yeah but uh he's
an eagle too so oh oh
you gotta we got an elite squad over
here coming to eagle records eagle
records has the in-house attorney
carl shout out carl fox so that [ __ ]
happens a lot cause because it's so
crazy that
there's no um
if you just have a tunecore account like
you could upload anything right and they
might you know if people aren't paying
attention but distrokit i think they got
a system now to where you got to approve
like if it's a certain name you type in
the yeah distro kid don't play they
don't play
i'm not sure tunecore is as as thorough
but digital kid don't play sure do you
still have stuff on distrokid i do got a
crazy little back catalogue that's you
know lovely was the was the first
project um on dish uh no love loss no
well that was on red six tape six tape
was was six tape on distrokid yeah oh
that's fire beautiful
you know i feel like
if if everybody could figure out what
they do
with just being able to assign points to
people
like i feel like they're like how how is
district kid the only [ __ ]
distributor that like
allows you to like hey hey sign up for
an account and i'll give you your points
you would think everyone has that but
they really it's like it's like a
distrokid thing it's like yeah it makes
sense
there's probably some other [ __ ] out
there we probably just it's not marketed
to the you know quite possibly yeah